you
everyone is Jerry let's have a look at
the game by the great josé raúl
capablanca he had the white pieces in
this one again civility arctic hour this
was played in New York 1924 and it's a
nice example of rook and pawn and
gameplay in particular the great
strengths the king and rook have when
they are coordinated well so let's dive
in and see how this one played out we
have a Dutch defense on board and
neither side waste any time very
efficient development for both Bishop
outside the pawn chain if there was one
player who made the biggest impression
on my own play as a younger player I'd
have to say it's capablanca gone through
plenty of his games and I enjoy his
simplistic style a lot of attention is
given to the e4 square in this game
multiple minor pieces are now pointing
there for each side
castles Queen e8 a typical pivot in the
Dutch preparing a transfer to the Kings
side and with move 9 Queen e2 White has
already connected rooks and is preparing
a central expansion so black wants to
stop this and does 94 offering a dark
square Bishop exchange and this happens
black isn't too quick to immediately
recapture once to create some weaknesses
and in the White Queen side captures on
c3 first and now there's a damaged
structure only now do we have a
recapture on e7 and incomes a4 so this
is a two-fold move one the idea is to
create some tension exchange off this
isolated pawn for a perfectly healthy
pawn and to stop the Queen from getting
active this is a potential pivot point
and from a3 she's quite the invasive
piece putting pressure on an isolated
pawn and a weak link on c3 so a4 rules
that out all together the rook is now
they are defending a3 so black ops for
this variation
creating a new imbalance in the position
minor peace and balance certainly other
avenues Knight c3 is perfectly fine
looking for Knight a5 but okay we have
Bishop takes Knight Queen takes Bishop
Knight c6 and rook F to be one so
working with this half open file there's
one downside here the doubled C pawns
but at the same time there's also some
play for one of the white rooks now that
the pawns are doubled B files half
opened an idea behind this point behind
this move is to meet the move Knight a5
with c5 so in the game it's rook to e8
but if Knight a5 is played White has c5
which is basically going to undo the
pawns white will be able to exchange off
the C pawn for the beep on the idea here
is to me captures with rook to b5 a
double attack white will soon be getting
the pawn back ok in the game its rook 88
some prep work for an e5 break white
plays Queen h3 this is coordinating well
with the bishop exerting pressure on f5
and h7 so this freezes both the e pawn
and the F pawn if the F pawn moves h7
collapses and if this guy moves f5
collapses and the other point behind
Queen to h3 is seen next to get the F
pawn contributing to some central
control and this ties in really well
with the bishop pawns on dark Bishop on
light Knight a5 Queen gets back involved
towards the center here supporting e4
and black repairs be 5 so this is where
things could really heat up white gives
up on this idea of preparing to play a
route to b5 move there's good reason for
that now we got these rooks that are
ready to be brought to life and
you know in just a moment with e5 the
e-file can open up the B file is not
where you want to be in this in this
case so we have a quick transfer the
rook is best placed on he 1 preparing
preparing to meet ePHI with e4 this is
where things could really heat up in the
game its Queen to d7 but if he 5 is in
white would strike right back just
creating a ton of tension and these pawn
exchanges are desirable for like having
the superior minor piece having the
long-range piece I should be saying
having the bishop more pawn exchanges
the better it would be nice to eliminate
this pawn so the bishop can see one of
the squares right next to the King okay
this doesn't hit Queen d7 in the game
white hits first
efore we have a capture Queen takes h7
is struck at g6 to defend and now the
next few moves just kind of
consolidating g3 for starters the Queen
no longer has to babysit King f8 is
preparing a d5 break adding some
security to the rook King f8
kingi to rook f7 expanding on the Kings
side now this is related to the bishop
well the pawn is trying to coordinate
with the bishop on g6 one day breaking
down this structure d5c takes he takes
and now
Queens are gone and what to do in this
position well first let's identify weak
points pawns are a big deal in this end
game where are the weak links for each
side for white c3 it's backward and a4
now of these two a c3 is the one that's
a bit more accessible the rook is not
long off from putting pressure on it
a4 it's not nearly as accessible notice
the the pawns that I'm highlighting over
here another reason why we may be
identifying them as weak or you know
potential targets in this endgame is
because the King is far away from
helping to defend them if there's
pressure on them so and you really don't
want to devote a bishop or a rook to
babysitting these weak points C 3 or a 4
you want to go on the offensive
so I mentioned a couple weak points in
White's camp what about black wears
black deficient well at the moment it
doesn't seem like there are any targets
in blacks camp until kappa blanka plays
h5 so now g6 certainly has some heat on
it two attackers one defender you have
to do something about that and you may
think to just take on h5 that this would
not be a good idea because after this
quick transfer of the rook to h1 this
pawn will be one next and once it's on
h5 an additional pawn will be one there
wouldn't be a way to defend both h7 and
d5 so what does black have to do babysit
g6 and there's still this idea in mind
to put pressure on the weak point we
have a caption on h6 so this is the weak
point for black this is the main weak
point for white
continuing we get some rook activity
croquette chuan open file and now Rick
h7 this is really the ideal placement
for the rook seventh-ranked cutting off
the king and in this endgame you want to
have the Kings contributing black King
cannot do that and the rook is observing
any of the black pawns that have not yet
moved prepared to pick them all off or
maybe even get behind one if it prepares
to bolt so one of the points behind King
to FA by the way is to sidestep a skewer
right if black tries to just hunt down
this pawn that's going to be painful so
the King goes to a dark square white
gets on the seventh rook c6 only now and
what to do about the c3 pawn well you
can't defend it so what is white - in
the meantime pushes upon and is it a
good choice to take on c3 it's not
if black takes this pawn White's gonna
take this pawn and who benefits white
for sure let's have a look at that if
this rook captures on c3 if both weak
pawns are captured well because the
white pawn is gone on c3 it doesn't mean
that black has now any passed pawns
whereas without the g6 pawn around white
has acquired passed pawns to in fact are
now connected and passed this is
enormous this would be enormous for
white this would not be a good exchange
for black to get to take the C pawn and
give up the Jeep on so like it's the
knight involved g5 not f5 no one
exchanged a weak pawn for a perfectly
healthy F pawn you want to win this pawn
if possible 93 King f3 and Knight to f5
so what just happened with the sequence
9th c4 III f5 the knight is simply
shielding the bishop from observing the
weak point which means the rook is now
ready to snip the c3 pawn and not lose
this weak point g6 so what does kappa's
idea here first it's a capture and after
the recapture pop-quiz to you what move
would you play in this position as white
feel free to pause the video ok
basically the winning plan here this
brilliant idea that kappa blanka had in
this game is to give up a couple pawns
in order to activate the King this rook
is already ideally placed doesn't get
any better than that
the King is cut off from any of the
action and if the King could only
somehow get involved getting near by the
King or nearby the rook there's all
sorts of mating threats or the
possibility to escort this pawn to
promotion
key move here is King g3c 3 now falls
with check but light moves forward and
will not stop moving forward either rook
f3 in the game is actually a losing move
not the best resistance with rook to f3
the computer is suggesting a6 will go
back to this position in a little bit in
the game we had rook to f3 and now pawn
pushes rook takes f4 another pawn goes
down with check King g5 and rook to e4
it's important that the rook not get too
greedy taking on e4 in this position
allows a super strong post the idea here
is not to take f5 this is a very nice
example this is a really a beautiful
game instructive game rook and pawn
endgame plenty of cases where you want
to actually hide behind an enemy pawn
why is this a good idea well you're not
vulnerable to some file checks you can
maintain your king position so if the
rook captured in this position on d4 the
King goes to f6 and what are you doing
about the main threat and this is the
this is the great strength I'm speaking
of when the king and rook are working
well together Rick on the 7th the King
nearby controlling these squares the
rook is ready just you hit black with
that game over move and also the pawn is
ready to push through
there's simply no good defense here for
Team Black as an example King e8 you
could multiple ways to do it but you
could just push straight away give a
check and eventually the rook has to
give itself up and this is a one
position for white so what is black do
black plays rook to e4 preparing to have
the rook come defend the back rank rook
to e8 move King f6 again not taking the
pawn using it to kind of shield the King
from some file checks
there's a mate threat King g8 defense
white inserts a check there's multiple
approaches here but I like this one best
kappa Blancas choice to insert the check
forcing the King on a square so that
went once the pawn moves it hits with
check so nice nice in between move
before snipping the c7 pawn
once more main thread is on board the
rook drops back to defend and while
black is now on their back foot
material at the moment black is up upon
black was up to ponds now is only up one
pond but not anymore material is now
balanced because of this great activity
with the white rook and King working
well together materials balanced and
black is just completely defensive the
king could never get active
so rookie four in the game King f6
renewing a mate threat rook f4 King e5
and after rook to g4 we have this pawn
push with check and it cannot be
captured if you enter a King and pawn
endgame this is simply winning for team
white this is just one quick example
this is how it would play out and yeah
this pawn now bolts so you can't take on
g7 King g8 in the game rook takes a
again notice how those those pawns are
just falling the rook is just enormous
on the seventh ring cutting the King
observing all the black pawns that
haven't moved we get a few more moves in
it wasn't long ago before white was down
two pawns now they're up two pawns and
black is completely dead
in fact after just a few more moves here
we have resignation by tartakower this
pawn there's no stopping it a couple
more moves the rook is there to defend
the promotion square black goes ahead
and resigns and if it continued b5 d7
here check here and of course we're
going to be winning this pawn and the
game soon enough
so a very instructive game I do want to
go back to this key moment
now that you see this this idea of the
king slipping in here is an important
moment this move here allows white to
establish a really strong King post on
f6 this must be prevented or black needs
to stay in a position to challenge the
king post on f6 how do you do this the
best move in this position is a six in
the game it was rook here quick replay
it was here here here and eventually the
King gets to f6 how do you combat this
strong King post on f6 this is how you
do it a six this is apparently the best
line to put up resistance here as black
a6 is preparing to create a passed pawn
with b5 so after a move like this we
would have b5 let's say a capture both
sides have a passer King here this pawn
could continue to push and here's the
idea King f6 you could challenge that
post because the rooks stays on c3
didn't go pawn hunting there would be
the move rook to c6 challenging the
strong King post so the strength of a
rook on the seventh rank combined with
that rook mating threats as well as
simply escorting this pawn to promotion
land it's a big deal it's a great
strength in the game and a really
brilliant play by the great kappa blanka
in this one okay as usual feel free to
leave any feedback to this video in the
comment section below and I will catch
you soon that's all for now take care
bye
you